queue up the overused clip from the
office because it's happening I mean we
knew it would but now that it's
officially official it feels oddly
comforting Elden ring is getting its
first DLC called shadow of the urge tree
the news came via a surprise
Announcement by The Game's official
Twitter account but unfortunately there
was no release date or release window
given all that we know is that the
expansion is currently in development
and will come out for PS4 PS5 Xbox One
series X and S and PC via steam details
about the expansion's price and content
are not available either though the
artwork for the Tweet could include some
hints as to what to expect let me know
all of your theories in the comments
below DLC for Elden ring has been
eagerly anticipated and expected for a
long time but from software has stayed
fairly quiet on the topic until now the
studio did release various patches Post
Release mostly aimed at fixing issues
and adding more PVP elements like the
free Coliseum update where players can
fight in Solo or multiplayer duels but
don't fret because even though that
expansion lacks a release date Final
Fantasy 16 has one and a producer for
the game told polygon it won't be
delayed unless quote a meteor falls on
Japan fingers crossed that doesn't
happen for a number of reasons the only
meteors are asteroids I want are in
Starfield but hold that thought we'll
come right back to that game let's keep
talking about Final Fantasy right now
previews for ff16 are popping up all
over the web today and based on early
reactions from fans the changes to
combat that are coming to the series
seem to be grabbing lots of attention
and our own coverage here at Gamespot
Steve watts compared the game to God of
War and Final Fantasy 16's director
Hiroshi takai agrees during our
interview about the game takai said
quote so just to give a simple example
of what our game cycle is closest to you
could probably say it's closest to God
of War we have our world map and in this
world map you'll have the main scenario
Quest that will unlock Clive will travel
to those areas and proceed with the main
quest and then after that you'll be able
to return to a hub area and from this
Hub area Clive will have new
opportunities for continuing the main
quest unlocking areas or also side
quests and side content the director
went on to explain how big of a fan he
is of kratos's Adventures and said quote
I cannot say I have not been influenced
by God of War meanwhile over on the kind
of funny gamescast Michael higham
compared the Final Fantasy 16 combat to
another series and said quote if you
want to get ready for Final Fantasy 16
play dmc5 Michael's reasoning is because
the two games share a combat director so
the DMC DNA is there and according to
Michael it felt right at home in Final
Fantasy make sure to check out the full
video preview we have a final fantasy 16
up on the channel right now and voiced
by Yours Truly you can also go over to
gamespot.com for more written coverage
and then shoot on over to funny games to
check out the rest of the podcast that I
quoted earlier and now let's get back to
Starfield because according to reporter
Andy Robinson an announcement for a
Starfield showcase may be imminent
Microsoft announced in January that
Starfield would get its own special
Showcase in 2023 just when this show
will Air however is still unknown at
this stage the game is expected to
launch in the first half of 2023 on Xbox
and PC following a delay from 2022 but
we're getting closer and closer to the
halfway mark of the year and we're still
missing a release date so let me know in
the comments your Starfield release
predictions and I'll see you tomorrow
thank you